Bienvenido al tercer video de la serie de
ejercicios de aplicación del álgebra
relacionados con problemas de edades.
Voy a retomar donde nos quedamos en el video
pasado, pues si recuerdan me confundí al final,
mientras ustedes están sentados tranquilamente,
yo me pongo nervioso de tener que explicarles.
Resulta que sí obtuvimos la respuesta correcta,
si Armando tiene 153 y Raúl tiene 765,
hace 85 años Armando tenía 68 años y Raúl tenía
680, lo cual cumple con que la edad de Raúl
era 10 veces la edad de Armando.
Así es que nuestra respuesta fue correcta
y estamos listos para abordar otro problema.
Borramos aquí...
muy bien...
necesito teclearlo y voy a teclearlo en letra grande...
El problema dice, Juan tiene 4 veces la
edad de Salman...
¡que coincidencia, este Salman aparece
por todos los problemas!
Juan tiene 4 veces la edad Salman,
Juan también es 3 años mayor que Salman.
¿Qué edad tiene Juan?
De hecho, es un problema directo, no tenemos
que ver con presente y futuro, solo tenemos
que ver con el presente.
Veamos cómo se resuelve.
Queremos encontrar la edad de Juan, así es que asignemos a la variable "j" la edad de Juan.
No me gusta este marcado grueso,
pero me voy a quedar con él.
Nos dice, Juan tiene 4 veces la edad de Salman...
no... no, voy a cambiar por el plumón delgado...
Así es que si Juan es "j", entonces esta primera oración vamos a encerrarla en un cuadrado.
Esta primera oración, Juan tiene 4 veces
la edad de Salman, podemos escribirla,
podemos traducirla a un ecuación de la
siguiente manera,
la edad de Sal es igual a la edad de Juan,
dividida entre 4 o también la podríamos
escribir como...
no, vamos a dejarla así...
Sal es igual a la edad de Juan dividido entre
4, ahora nos dicen que Juan también es
3 años mayor que Salman, esto significa entonces
que la edad de Sal es igual a la edad de Juan,
la edad de Juan menos 3.
La primera oración, la edad de Juan es 4
veces la edad de Sal, es esta ecuación de
aquí, la edad de Sal es la edad de Juan dividida entre 4.
Y la segunda oración, Juan es también 3
años mayor que Salman, significa que si tienes
la edad de Juan y le restas 3 años,
obtienes la edad de Sal.
Bien, ya tenemos nuestra ecuación, de hecho,
en vez de haber escrito Juan podía haber
escrito directamente "j", así es que hemos
obtenido la ecuación, "j" sobre 4 es igual
a "j" menos 3, multiplicamos por 4 ambos lados
de la ecuación y obtenemos que "j" es igual
a "4j" menos 12, aplicamos la propiedad distributiva
y esto saltándonos algunos pasos nos resulta
en que "3j" es igual a 12, para concluir que
Juan tiene 4 años de edad.
Si Juan tiene 4 años, esta oración que Juan
tiene 4 veces la edad de Sal significa que
Sal tiene 1 años de edad, también dice que
Juan tiene 3 años más que Salman, nuestra
respuesta es consistente pues 4 es igual a 3 más 1.
Estamos en lo correcto, la edad de Juan es
exactamente 4 años.
Espero que esto te sea útil, diviértete.
Ya has visto varios problemas de aplicación
relacionados con las edades, si aun te parece
confuso puedes volver a ver los videos, quizás
ponerle pausa una vez que el problema está
escrito, para ver si lo puedes resolver por tu cuenta.
Recuerda que tienes para entretenerte, una
gran cantidad de problemas por resolver,
en los diversos módulos que te ofrecemos.
Diviértete.